there was an interesting exchange on cnn
during an interview
with uh donald trump's economic adviser
larry kudlow and kudlow didn't
necessarily seem drunk this time
although he did have some interesting
hiccups during the interview and and
some some kind of strange slurring but
he he wasn't making sense regardless of
whether he had been drinking i think is
the point i'm trying to make and larry
kudlow tried telling cnn anchor jake
tapper
that the united states is dealing with
coronavirus in a safe way
and that the trump administration has
figured out how to do it now fact check
before we watch the video
as of right now the united states is the
major country with the eighth
most cases per capita in the world and
the ace
eighth most deaths per capita in the
world now when i say major country
there are tiny uh territories like san
marino for example
which have worse numbers on a per capita
basis than the us
it only moves the u.s up two spots so so
so it's not a
a big change in either case but trump
and people around him
despite these horrible numbers continue
to insist
partially out of desperation partially
out of dishonesty that the united states
is just doing great on the virus
and larry kudlow tried saying it to jake
tapper and jake tapper just laughed in
larry kudlow's face and it's compelling
to watch let's take a look
and kudlow you will hear shifting
directly from singing the praises of the
economy
into singing trump's praises on
coronavirus and jake tapper just can't
take it
my point is this we are in a strong
rebound
lower taxes and lower regulations going
way back
are still in place and businesses are
reopening we are learning to deal with
the virus
in a targeted safe prevented way so
no it's not dependent all i'm saying is
a little
some targeted assistance would go a long
way we're not we're not learning to live
with the virus larry that
we just had four days in a row of more
than 50 000 infections the death rate is
the highest in the world but
let's focus on the the economic aspect
because that's your area of expertise
i guess one i just want to say yeah just
jake wants to check one just one second
i want to clarify living with the virus
look
uh 5 000 experts just signed a petition
uh led by people from harvard stanford
oxford university
these are scientists these are doctors
these are health care workers who say
we can deal with this virus going on
while
we're getting new therapies we're
getting new vaccines are coming around
it's not just living with the virus as
long as we protect the most vulnerable
as long as we preserve the key
guidelines yes we can get through this
we are not going to shut down the whole
economy no nobody there is no reason for
that
we will take care of the vulnerable
that's the key point well
and there's so much that you just said
but again i had you on to talk about the
economy not not health care matters in
terms of
obeying by the key guidelines i mean you
might want to tell the guy in the
building behind you but that's a
separate issue
so jake's mistake there is he referred
to the building behind kudlow as if
kudlow was
at the white house and it said on screen
kudlow was actually
at his country estate in connecticut for
the interview
not at the white house but jake tapper
is right to laugh
record number of cases for the last two
months
once again four days ago over the
weekend
and if we want to look not just at one
day but at the seven day moving average
the average cases have been increasing
since september 13th so we are now
a full month into another spike
and remember when you look at this graph
you see we had that first spike into mid
april
and then we got back down to about 20
000 cases a day and for some reason at
20 000 cases a day
everything opened up and then we spiked
to 75
000 cases a day in mid-july you can see
it on the graph
now we've had more openings since
dipping
to 35 000 cases a day and we're back up
to 50 cases a day so
unfortunately there are people who saw
getting down to 35 000 cases a day
as a victory it's not a victory and if
this trend continues
the next peak could be a hundred
thousand cases a day and if that's the
case
it is going to be a very very dark
winter both the uh
literally as uh the clocks get ready to
change
uh and and it is going to be this sunset
will be very early in the northeast
and metaphorically it will be a very
dark winter as dr fauci said
we need to get down to an average of 10
000 cases a day
to even remotely being able to say we
are controlling the virus
and even 10 000 cases a day is a lot the
last time
think about this number the last time we
had only 10 000 cases per day
was last march since then every day
there are at least 10 000 cases some
days as many as 75 000 cases now as far
as larry kudlow is concerned
kudlow said back in february that the
trump administration had contained the
virus february i mean it's laughable
and as a reminder the official
coronavirus death toll
is likely way too low in the united
states this is something
we talked about maybe two months ago and
i think is worth revisiting
officially 221 thousand 222
have died from coronavirus that's a
massive
stunning tragic number and it didn't
have to be that way but that's the
official
number mortality in the united states
was more than 280 000 deaths higher
than during the first eight months of
2020
then sorry during the first eight months
of 2020
mortality was more than 280 000 deaths
higher
than during any previous fought period
of the first eight months of the year
going back five years
so again it looks like the official
death toll of 221
is well below the real coronavirus death
toll
and you also have to remember because of
the virus fewer people are traveling
fewer people are walking around driving
around
you probably have to subtract out some
deaths
from some other causes because there are
people
just sitting at home reducing the number
of deaths from
other causes this year but kudlow and
others and trump himself continue to
insist we've won
we're winning we're the best it's over i
don't know that anybody believes it at
this point i think even when they
interview trumpists at rallies and they
say we've won
i don't even know that they believe it
to be totally honest with you
if you are anything like me you probably
aren't thrilled with the idea of going
into
a doctor's office right now and
thankfully there is a
practical and affordable way to take
control of your health
and get personalized care from the
comfort of your home
it's a service called steady md they're
one of our sponsors
you take a quiz you get matched with a
licensed
primary care physician who understands
your health needs you have a one hour
video call with your new doctor you
establish a meaningful relationship with
them and after that
your doctor is available to you anytime
by text phone
or video chat this is not a random
doctor on call
each doctor at steady md has a limited
number of patients so they actually have
time
to listen to you you get the personal
attention that you deserve
they can do almost everything an
in-person doctor
can do perform medical evaluations talk
to you about health concerns
send prescriptions to your home or local
pharmacy
and anything they can't do online
they'll quickly set you up with
an in-person provider to do things like
blood tests as an example
you don't need insurance it's only 99
bucks a month with
no other fees or co-pays there are so
many
practical advantages to using steady md
for primary care
and it's also so much more affordable
go to steadymd.com pacman to take the
free quiz see which doctor is right for
you i took their quiz they matched me
with a doctor
who specializes in my particular health
needs and situation the doctor they gave
me
is a really perfect fit for me and my
medical needs there's no risk no
commitment to get started
just click the link right underneath
this video